how do you feel about the quote never
let your techniques show I mean I think
it's a good quote I mean I think I think
that is I think the I think skillful
people skillful people at their craft
know how to do that well I think I for
example I think story structure is great
I'm a big story structure nerd I love I
love McKee and Syd field and Blake
Snyder and all those guys I love all
that we're story structure I think gets
a bad rap is when people use story
structure but they're not good enough to
cover it up and and then it like they
let they like the technique show the
great writers though I think use the
structure and then they're good enough
to weave such a tapestry around that
structure that it's structured but you
don't care you don't realize it's there
that's where I think the sweet spot is
and so in that regards I'm 100% in
agreeance not to let the technique show
I mean if it's like for me it's it's you
know if you stripped all everybody down
to the bones all of your skeletons will
look pretty similar but it but the thing
that makes us all unique is when you
guys start layering in you know all the
different aspects of how we look even to
the way we dress right once we add in
all that stuff now we're all super
unique and super different and super
interesting and that that I think is
what makes us individual people and so
so people that let the technique show
are I think I think struggle with
struggle with executing in such a way to
like to bury it under their creative eye
I think people take that quote though to
mean that technique isn't good like
technique is somehow a bad thing that
technique is somehow this like
restrictive pejorative sort of a of a
thing whether it's story structure
whatever it is I think technique gets a
bad rap in that way so I'm a I'm a huge
advocate for strategy and technique but
great creators and this is where the art
comes in is the art comes in is how do
you use the technique and use the
structure and then layer on top of that
so much creativity and such amazing
ideas that people don't see it though
it's always there if somebody left a
funny comment on one of our videos and
they said oh yeah
you you're taking your your structures
great and you have the inciting incident
on this but just your script is horrible
but it's - hey great structure you know
I mean essentially kind of making fun of
the fact that yeah if you don't have a
great story then all of that is wasted
sure matter it's it's it's you know
entertainment is not paint-by-numbers
and that's and that's the variable that
will always be the variable is that
whether it's Blake Snyder or Syd field
or Robert McKee or whether you're doing
super story transmedia stuff like you
can have it all mapped out but the great
variable is are you good enough to
execute and because yeah technically
your inciting incident can be here and
you're your act to Turning Point is here
and you know the dark night of the soul
was here and it's all placed very well
but but if you can't if you can't
execute in a way that makes people
forget about the technique then then
it's just I think it's just a reflection
on your talent or you maybe just thing
to rewrite maybe you just you need to
take some more time with it to be able
to show your talent that being said I
think technique is necessary sure and
and so I think a lot of times people
throw throw the baby out with the
bathwater so to speak and saying well
you know story structure that's that we
don't need that it doesn't matter where
your inciting incident is it doesn't
matter if you have three acts
you know excetera et cetera i'm i don't
go that far at all I think that stuff is
necessary you just got to be good enough
to make people forget about it
you